Apple roared into the TV game with a  morning show a superb drama about the  importance of dignity and doing the  right thing made by a company that runs  sweatshops in China so on their new iOS  update it's actually insane what they  are doing as literally millions of  people in China are standing up against  the government so that they can go live  their lives and not be trapped in condos  Apple literally updated the app did not  put it in the text of the update that  airdrop was going to be shut off and  limited and that way people couldn't  share videos  you support the Chinese people's right  to protest  do you regret restricting airdrop access  that protesters used to evade  surveillance from the Chinese government  it'd be a kind of quiet in essence they  don't want people to know what's going  on in China and apple is helping them do  it China's done an unbelievable job and  we should all applaud that